months
and you can remove your mask when you're
at the audio so you can see
good afternoon dear colleagues
the next item on the agenda is the
debate
with the prime minister of estonia
the eu's role
in the changing world and the security
situation of europe following the
russian aggression
and invasion of
ukraine
let me start by saying dear prime
minister dear kaya dear colleagues
this session today is devoted to one of
the most pressing issues
the eu's
changing role
in a changing world
putin's invasion shattered the peace our
generation has known
it has changed
everything
and europe's response must be
proportionate to the serious
real
and growing threat to our collective
security
so we need to reassess
the european union's role in this new
world
we need to boost our investment in
defense
and in innovative technologies
this is the time for us
to take decisive steps to ensure the
security of all europeans
the time to build a real
security and defense union
and reduce our dependencies on the
kremlin
what we have seen so far in terms of
european coordination solidarity and
unity is unprecedented and this must be
the blueprint of what we do going
forward
our people in our states have welcomed
more than 1.5 million ukrainians into
our communities
our homes and our hearts
we have matched massive sanctions with
practical solidarity in a show
of european values and i know we can go
further still
and we must all do
what we can
we have with us today prime minister
of estonia
thank you
for accepting our invitation to address
the parliament and the people of europe
as part of our new this is europe
debates where
different eu leaders can be present to
discuss
our common agenda
we are also so pleased to welcome you
back among us now as prime minister of
estonia
a member state of the european union
that shares a near 300 kilometer border
with russia
let me assure you prime minister that
you will find us together in opposing
this invasion
in ensuring a clear response to dealing
with the kremlin and in ensuring that
democracy prevails
we stand together for ukraine
we stand together with ukraine prime
minister you have the floor
[Applause]
honorable president metzeler esteemed
members of the parliament
dear guests
it's an honor and a privilege to be
speaking here today
the european parliament is not only a
house of european democracy
it has also been my political base for
four years
so here i feel at home i feel among
friends
sadly our fellow europeans in ukraine
cannot say the same
they are fighting for their homeland
for their loved ones their freedom to
choose their own destiny
the ukrainian armed forces are putting
up a fierce resistance that president
putin did not expect
ordinary people are on the streets
showing
the flag to the invading army inviting
them to go home
ukrainian farmers have become famous for
towing captured tanks back home
one story circulating the social media
even speaks of a woman who downed the
russian drone by throwing a jar of
pickles at it later she contested that
it was a jar of
pickled tomatoes
how
asked the commentator
did they expect to occupy this country
at the same time many others are
streaming across borders over 2 million
have reached safety in the european
union
these refugees will keep coming in the
words of one humanitarian worker
in a conflict always watch which way the
refugees are going
in the current war they are headed for
the european union not for russia
putin's war is an act of raw military
aggression against an independent and
sovereign country that wants nothing
more than to fulfill its own european
dream
the aim is to terrorize civilians we
have seen it before in grozny we have
seen it in aleppo
kindergartens hospitals residential
buildings are targeted in contravention
to the international humanitarian law
you have been doom scrolling on your
phones just like i have so i do not need
to tell you of the atrocities taking
place now every day
in places like harkev
mario paul as well as kiev where many
people are without water electricity
food
putin's war has also left ordinary
russians without access to the truth
they are living in isolated infraspace
we thought that in times of the internet
this could no longer be possible but it
is
our task is to break the wall of lies
it is a complicated task we need to
mobilize our technological potential to
win the war for truth
and it goes without saying that global
internet platforms have a huge role to
play
if you allow me madam president i would
also like to address the russian people
directly
dear russian friends
the european union is not acting against
you
our measures are intended to isolate
president putin and his government which
is conducting a brutal war against
ukraine
you are now seeing only the beginnings
of deprivation which will become much
worse
as our sanctions kick in
your government is already instituting
practices
that are familiar to me from the soviet
times
like censorship
like threatening journalists with the
15-year present sentences for speaking
about the war
like rationing for foodstuffs
like asking teachers to report on the
political sympathies of their pupils and
their parents
global companies are pulling out of
russia airlines are no longer flying
you can no longer use your visa and
mastercards
none of this is directed against you
it is directed against president putin
and his government
we understand that it hurts you but it
also hurts us
it hurts you because autocrat does not
care for the people he only cares for
his power
that is something that is so hard to
understand in a democratic world
last year's nobel peace prize laureate
nova gazetta editor-in-chief dmitry
morato called this a question between
and i quote
people for the state or the state for
the people
dear russian friends
we continue to hope for a democratic and
stable russia that is respectful of its
neighbors and is governed by a rule of
law
madam president dear members
since the 24th of february which
coincidentally was the
104th anniversary of estonian's
independence
the world has changed
president putin's invasion of ukraine
has ushered in a period of insecurity on
our continent that we have not seen
since the 1939
and like we saw after the second world
war our world will not return to the
seitus quo ante
russia's relationship with the outside
world will be different
how to restore the trust in respecting
international law and order
european attitudes towards security will
be different and our institutional
setups will need to adjust
and we might just have rediscovered what
the liberal international
rules-based order was all about in the
first place
so in short we will in the future speak
about before times and the after times
the free world has already begun to
respond and the european union has been
at the forefront of this response which
itself is a welcome change
the eu is not normally seen to be
particularly nimble organization but in
terms of security we have changed more
in the last couple of weeks than we have
in last 30 years
we have imposed three packages of tough
sanctions on top of those existing
already since russia's invasion to
donbas and annexation of crimea in
2014.
we have frozen assets stopped moscow's
asset access to its reserves held abroad
and thrown russia out of swift
we have closed our airspace to russian
registered owned and operated aircraft
we have shut down disinformation
channels masquerading as media outlets
and we have acted to use the european
peace facility to send a half a billion
euros in much needed defensive weapons
and non-lethal aid to ukraine
the eu has acted with an urgency
conviction and unity that has surprised
president putin
and the world and their dare i say we
have also surprised ourselves
we have indeed acted as a joe political
union
our citizens have responded as well by
opening their pocketbooks and their
hearts by welcoming refugees often into
their own homes
by volunteering on humanitarian missions
by collecting food clothing and
medicines for those fleeing the war
and let's not forget about the irish
fishermen our citizens are showing a
generosity of spirit that makes me proud
to be estonian
and proud to be european
i know a bit about kindness of strangers
as many of you know i am the child of
deportees whom stalin sent away to
siberia
my mother was just six months old when
she was deported on a cattle car along
with her mother and grandmother to what
the estonians call the cold land
it was a stranger who gave my
grandmother a jar of milk that kept my
mother alive during this journey
it were strangers who dried the baby's
diapers on their skin as it was the only
warm place in the cattle car
and it were strangers who helped in
untold ways when they were allowed to
return to estonia
so you could say we estonians have some
experience in being deported and fleeing
wars and we also have some experience
with russia
which we have been trying to share with
the european union since we joined
it was 78 years ago today
when the red army bombed my home city
telling to the
ground but my mother
the same baby who took her first trip
abroad to siberia
always taught me that it was impolite to
say i told you so
madam president dear members
we are in this for the long haul
we will have to exercise strategic
patience because peace is not going to
break out tomorrow
russia expects us to make a step back
soon
as dmitry medvedev explained to putin in
a recent public meeting of the russian
security council and i quote
sooner or later they the west
will get tired of their own initiative
they will come to ask us about returning
to discussions and negotiations
regarding all the matters of strategic
security
end of quote
putin will come to test us and yes we
will have to resist
that means that we need to keep
supporting those fighting for ukraine's
independence while giving time for the
sanctions and isolating measures to work
to their full capacity
this will require a sustained effort
from all of us
but we need also to think about what
comes next
i see two areas of action
first we need to hardwire our
fundamental change of heart into policy
of smart containment
we all want the democratic and secure
russia
this house expressed that desire last
year when it honored a russian
opposition leader alexander
alexey navalny with soccer of price
but what i mean by hardwiring is that we
need how we need now to consolidate with
the free world
what the free world has accomplished in
the last weeks and build on it
we need to do this together with our
trusted transatlantic partners and
others who are like-minded
and there are many like-minded partners
if you look last week's u.n general
assembly the vast majority of the world
community
141 states
voted to condemn russia's military
aggression against ukraine
this vote demonstrates not only a
victory of multilateralism
but the win for the rule of law
we also need collectively to give our
strongest support to the international
criminal court once the time comes
last week icc prosecutor kareem khan
announced that 39 state parties to the
rome statute
had referred the situation to his office
this enables him to go ahead with the
investigation in any past and present
war crimes crimes against humanity and
genocide committed
on any part of the territory of ukraine
by any person
here in the european union we need to
push harder and faster to cut our energy
dependence on russian gas and oil
because because we have already
committed to the green transition this
will be a win-win for our energy
independence but also good for the
planet
we also need to move quickly to
synchronize ukraine's power grid with
that of continental europe
and make sure all parts of the eu are
synchronized into that continental grid
as well
turning to defense our decisions of last
week to use the european peace facility
to assist ukraine are but the first step
towards strengthening our own
continental security
we must transform our deterrent posture
into a defense plan
i'm mindful that not all european
members are nato allies
when my father was leading the estonian
negotiations to join nato he was often
asked why do you need this
russia does not pose a threat anymore
well we knew our neighbor then and we
also know our neighbor now
i can only be grateful to the decision
to join the defense alliance but being
part of the alliance
also comes with the obligations
the two percent of the gdp defense
spending target must become an absolute
minimum requirement
estonia decided this already ten years
ago
and allow me here to thank germany for
having taken the previously unimaginable
decision
of raising its defense spending to to
two percent
all of europe thanks you
let me say here clearly that as we
strengthen european defense we need to
work hand in hand with nato
time after time we have agreed that
stronger europe means stronger nato
just the stronger nato implies a
stronger european defense
i look forward to a third joint
declaration between the eu and nato on
the matter
a stronger european defense means
planning our spending wisely and in
coordination
we must concentrate on those
capabilities that are too expensive for
any individual member state to develop
on their own
such as long air defense including
missile defense
our european capabilities need to be
mobile so we can move them quickly if we
need to
and and they need to be state of the art
russia may have an enormous military
force but we can compete with quality
breakthrough technology i urge all
member states to submit only pesco
projects that bring technological
technological innovation to the table
and here is a sobering thought
in stepping up european defense we must
find a consensus within the eu
that sometimes the best way of achieving
peace is the willingness to use military
strength
these are my thoughts on the need of
policy of smart containment
let me now turn to the second area where
we should concentrate as we think of the
post-war order
and this is the future of ukraine
madam president tear members
ukraine came under attack in 2014
because it wanted to join the european
union
it came under armed attack on the 24th
of february because it seeks to take its
rightful place among us it is in our
interest that ukraine becomes more
stable more prosperous and solidly
founded on the rule of law
i know from estonia's own experience
that this is how it works
but it's not only in our interest to
give ukraine a membership perspective it
is also our moral duty to do so
ukraine is not fighting for ukraine it's
also fighting for europe
if not now
then when
i thank you for your attention
thank you thank you very much
prime minister i give the flaw now to
the high representative and vice
president of the commission joseph boren
but
members
of the european parliament
thank you to the prime minister of
estonia miscalas
for setting so clearly
what is at stake
her presentation has been
so complete
that i'm afraid
it would be difficult for me not to
repeat what you have already said
i will try
i will try not to repeat what
the prime minister has said
and you
already know
and i want to
and i want to to bring to this house a
double message
first
we have done a lot
second
we have done enough
first we have done a lot
breaking the booth
and advancing something that was
unthinkable
some days or hours before
but certainly it's not enough and we
should have done it quicker
so let's be self-praising
but at the same time let's be
self-critical
because
the challenges that we are facing
will require
a strong stance from our side
and will require to be ready to pay a
price
to pay a price because the consequences
of
the war
will be
long lasting
and the consequences of this war
will be shaping
the european policies
for the years
and for the decades to come
we are going to face the problem of
gas supply
refugees changing
above all
what do we understand by
security and defense policy of the
european union
and
fragmentation
of the world economy
that will certainly result
from the
weaponization of interdependency
which is no longer something to be
discussed on academic circles is not an
abstract concept it's a reality
weaponization of interdependency
and certainly we are dependent on
russian gas
and the first thing to do is to cancel
this dependency
dear members of the european parliament
when the phone
rang at five o'clock in the morning
two weeks ago
i my head of cabinet voice told me
they have started bombing gif
i felt the page of history turning
and i felt that we were entering
in an ueda
in a new moment of the history
in an occasion in which we europeans we
should be able
to really face the challenge that russia
is putting to us
and in order not to repeat what the
miss president mr prime minister has
already said
allow me to make some evaluations
about in general terms what's going on
on this new era
of our history
the first one is that
the fact that we europeans don't like
woe
doesn't uh allow us not to think about
goal
we europeans we
do not like war but we have waged war
amongst each other it has left us with a
bitter taste
now we no longer want to wage war but
that doesn't mean other people don't
want to
you need multiple sides to come to peace
but only one side to wage war
and now we are facing this war because
putin has a certain vision of a history
that is completely different to ours
his way of thinking is completely
different
to us and that is why he has done what
he has done
that is why
we
need to face this knowing that he is
mistaken
putin believed that ukraine was weak and
servile but he has met a strong and
resistant country
he felt that europe was too
weakened and divided and too dependent
on its gas to show a united front
he felt that the united states were too
concerned with china to look to what was
happening in europe he thought that the
division between europe and the us was
sufficiently wide
so we would not unite as we have done
he thought his army would be capable of
crushing ukraine in just a few days in
occupying kiev and putting in place a
puppet government but all of this has
not come to pass
this war will continue
and
we
will have to
deal with the circumstances as they come
one of the considerations we have to
look at is our economic global
interdependence but that does not change
the relations and powers of force
our
trade relations are a good way to build
a peaceful world but it is not
sufficient
it is not sufficient when faced with
people who do not share our values of
liberal democracy
i believe lenin said when speaking of
capitalists they would be uh
willing to sell almost anything if it
brought them
benefits to themselves
and he believed uh putin that the
russians would be sufficiently strong
that we would back down in the face of
war in ukraine
he believed our energy ties with russia
would paralyze us
now it's true
we are affected by our energy ties
when it comes to oil and
gas we are paying the equivalent of the
amount of assets that have been frozen
owned by the russian central bank
so we have blocked these reserves but we
haven't stopped the flows now obviously
these reserves are an accumulation of
these flows
now
he put aside certain currency reserves
in
dollars and euros to put them into
chinese currency for example currencies
that were outside of our control so the
first thing that we need to do is to cut
the umbilical cord that links us with
the russian economy we need to stop
these flows that allow them to gain
assets to finance this war
[Applause]
this is something that we can do at a
macro political level as the commission
did yesterday with a new directive
that
means that by the end of the year we
will have cut our dependence on russian
energy by two-thirds it is a difficult
objective but something which is
achievable if we really put our minds to
it and this requires macroeconomic
measures technical measures
it also means that european citizens
need to turn the heat down in their
houses everybody needs to make an
individual effort when it comes to
cutting use of gas
the same way we would use less water if
there was a drought and the same way we
all work together to wear masks to
tackle covered
the communal efforts we made
in the face
we need to make a collective commitment
we started too late but it is better
late than never
when we saw the invasion
in crimea we knew we had to reduce our
dependence on russian energy but
actually we only increased it instead of
decreasing it
and now it is high time that
systematically permanently consistently
we reduce our dependence on russian oil
and gas
defending our liberal
values
will not be possible unless there is a
political commitment and citizens
willing to pay a price for this it would
simply be a chimera
it would be empty words unless we are
willing to act to be more united to be
more coordinated
and to pay the inevitable price that any
kind of structural change
will bring such as changing the energy
mix of an entire
continent we also
need to tackle
the narrative
i was speaking to
uh
people from
uh
the
middle east from china uh
people believe
uh that we
westerners or those in ukraine started
the war that we were
using nuclear threats that the fault was
on our side
starting this third world war as they
called it so it's very important to
tackle that
way of thinking
and we also need to develop our
own
facts
we need to get the information across
i think there's a huge amount of
diplomatic work
to be done
we have to speak loudly from the side of
europe to explain what is really
happening
not everybody has the same clear
vision of what is happening in ukraine
we have false messages propaganda lies
which can contaminate the minds of those
who do not have any further information
than that so it is our
information to provide
those
facts that truth
of what is happening
on the ground
it's important also to separate the
regime of putin from the russian people
now we have called this war putin's war
and it is his war
he is the one that decided to wage this
war
and i think it's important that we make
a distinction
between one person supported by a regime
supported by oligarchs
based on corruption on exploiting the
wealth of a country and on the other
hand
the russian people who have come out on
the streets to protest against the war
thousands of citizens who have been
imprisoned because they protested in
russia they deserve our solidarity and
support
as do the citizens of ukraine
this
conflict will
last it will be like covert it's not
just going to disappear overnight it is
going to leave a mark on history
the way this war develops will develop
on a number of factors that we don't
necessarily control
the
balance of military power on the ground
i think it's important therefore that we
provide military
support to the people and to the army of
ukraine
secondly the consequences of the
sanctions that we have
applied against
russia the financial and economic
sanctions
the
russian economy is not that interlinked
with the global economy it is basically
pumping out
gas
and it uses money from these energy
transactions to
fund its military to
expand its influence where it can to the
caucasus now to ukraine so it will
depend what effect these sanctions have
it seems russia is now risking default
on some of its external debt
the fall of the ruble has been
um
very striking
it shows
the weakening of the economy but
unfortunately this will also have
an impact on the people
unfortunately though these sanctions
will not
show effect in the next few days it's
something that will take place over the
longer term
we need to continue
increasing pressure through the
options that we have
member states are working on a new
um package of sanctions it involves
around 100 people responsible at
different levels of government more
economic sanctions i hope that these
will be adopted before the end of this
session today
it also depends on the international
mobilization against the war
we
should be proud of the
extraordinary diplomatic solidarity 141
countries uh supported
ukraine and only four supported russia
we have north korea
belarusia belarusia and eritrea so
were also a lot of companies which
abstained
uh there were abstentions in africa it's
important to understand this in the
context of what is happening in the
world we need to strengthen our ties
with countries that for one reason or
another through fear of russia perhaps
those
who are concerned about showing an
independence of thought and action
rather than condem
russia they chose to abstain or not
participate in the vote
north and south america has been very
united when it comes to condemning
russia africa not so much
from a geopolitical point of view we
really need to
focus on
links to african countries so that we
can be united when we come to a critical
moment such as this one
putin
tried to
invade
the cities rapidly he wanted to take
kiev in just a week but kiev is still
resisting all of the ukrainian cities
are resisting
the
russian army is
doing the only thing he knows how to do
in response bombing it did this in
aleppo across all of syria in
chechnya and it will do the same now in
ukraine
without any concern for the civilian
casualties
there are humanitarian corridors being
open but on the condition that they lead
to russia and then bombing people when
they try to use these
humanitarian corridors
and we condemn this in the strongest
possible terms
now
there is more diplomatic work that needs
to be done
we have condemned this strongly but we
also need to continue working to try and
achieve a ceasefire to have
peace talks between ukraine and russia
under the auspices of the united nations
we need to rethink
what we
want to do here
when we will activate the articles of
the treaty that promise that europe will
build a common defense
system not
in parallel to nato but a complement to
nato
we need more commitment more political
will
we need to increase our security our
defense
let me
say
i think it's very good that germany has
taken the first step along this path
nobody likes to say to their citizens
that they're increasing their military
efforts
we
all uh
prefer a carrot rather than a stick
approach
but
when the helsinki agreements were signed
we saw around a 4 spending on defense of
gdp on average
and now we have 1.5 percent of gdp spent
on defense so from four percent to 1.5
percent during a year of a period of 50
years of peace now
that could be justified when the
dividends of
peace were used to improve social
security for example well-being
but now when we look at the challenges
that we are facing it would
be to ignore reality if we not did not
do the necessary awareness raising and
explain to our citizens that our way of
life does come with a cost
we want to have
everything organized very uh neatly like
a formal french garden but out there the
jungle is growing and if we don't want
the jungle to invade our neatly
manicured lawns and garden we need to do
more than just maintain it we need to
defend it from gibraltar all the way to
the caucasus
we are surrounded by a ring of fire
including amongst others russia if we
look at the caucasus if we look at syria
if we look at the sahel
europeans
need to
understand that these bombs falling on
kiev
that is a wake-up call from our dream of
well-being and prosperity we have to
face these challenges we did not look
for these challenges but these are the
ones that we face now and ukraine is our
number one priority please use less gas
reduce our dependence on russia as they
attack ukraine make more commitment to
our collective defense that is an
obligation
under the treaties and i think we have
not paid sufficient attention to that up
to now thank you i now pass
to the speakers
on behalf of the political group
starting with the epp group arno dungeon
madam president prime minister high
representative
for 30 years now
since the yugoslav war we've had an
opportunity for uh europe to reawaken
but when it comes to defense progress
has never lived up to the public
statements
the russian invasion of ukraine is the
start of a new era and europe has to
draw the necessary consequences
what does this mean in practice well
finally we need the european strategic
compass we have instruments at our
disposal that just need to be used
what we have lacked are not tools and
instruments no what we've lacked is
unanimous simultaneous political will
from our member states we depend
entirely
uh
on the terms of the lisbon treaty
articles
47 article 44 et cetera but these have
never been activated
we understand the importance of these uh
budget lines but we have never been able
to actually
stock them up properly what about
intervention
forces we've had the famous battle
groups in place for 20 years now
we know what we lack
all of our technical shortcomings have
been identified and they are clearly uh
labeled in
european parliament reports every single
year
we have a european defense industry that
it performs well and is capable of
rising to the channel challenge
please
could we please not have these
industries subject to the taxonomy
regulations commission we're talking to
you here
important announcements have been made
by european leaders recently but
europe's credibility depends on the long
term we need
on irreversible political will the worst
thing i can imagine is coming back here
in a couple of months time
understanding that our efforts have been
relaxed
now on behalf of the s d group i invite
iracia garcia perez to take the floor
thank you madam president
prime minister ms kallus welcome to the
european parliament where you belong uh
the criminal attack
by putin
has held up a mirror
to us of our own strengths and
weaknesses as a european union the
wavering that we have traditionally
shown towards the kremlin contrasts with
the forceful measures that have been
taken since the outbreak of the war in
particular
the agreement on economic sanctions and
the change in our asylum policy which is
a contrast to the shameful closure of
borders against the syrians in 2015. in
a few days we have taken a gigantic step
along the path
to becoming a global power once again we
have proof that the european union is
forged under the impact of crises and
the time has now come to take critical
stock of ourselves to learn from our
mistakes
never again should we sacrifice human
rights for gas
it is
necessary to create strategic reserves
of gas to jointly purchase it and
connect the iberian peninsula to make it
a center of storage regarification
distribution of liquid national gas this
is imperative and urgent
imposing levies on electric electricity
companies who do not invest in
renewables is also
an imperative necessity because every
any every euro that we invest in green
energy reduces our strategic
vulnerability we also need a road map to
correct the mistakes that we made in the
refugee crisis of 2015
we need to activate the directive on
temporary protection which obliges
member states to provide
shelter food education health and work
to refugees and now we have to agree on
a fair distribution of
refugees and establish a proper
mechanism for
reception
this is an opportunity to design a new
migration policy which is based this
time on responsibility and solidarity we
also have to prepare to support the
ukrainian population we never wanted a
war putin is the sole responsible for
this today
the weapons which are helping a free
ukraine to survive are the very weapons
that the second spanish republic did not
have 80 years ago because of the failure
of european democracies to act
in this tragic moment for the ukrainian
army we have to supply
weapons to help them defend innocent men
women and children their safety is our
safety because nobody in europe is going
to be safe if putin has his way the
killing of civilians violates the rules
of war laid down in the geneva
conventions and it is a matter of
urgency for the united nations to
organize humanitarian
corridors and the international criminal
court has to move ahead in investigating
putin as a war criminal
in its mediating role china must set
aside its ambiguity and offer tangible
action to guarantee peace
the solution to the cowardly aggression
of putin cannot be the surrender of
ukraine or the amputation of any of its
territory any concession to putin
um we have to say loud and clear to
putin that
any democratic european state has the
right to become a member of the european
union including ukraine it is now time
for us to express our absolute support
to the baltic countries and all
countries who have borders with ukraine
and russia
we have seen for ourselves i have seen
for myself the strength of solidarity on
the border between ukraine and hungary
the admiral work of the red cross and
those unsung
volunteers who are
providing the immediate needs covering
the immediate needs of refugees arriving
at our borders we have to use this
solidarity shown by our citizens to give
us a stronger sense of european identity
and
move forward
in fighting against tyrants like putin
the time has come that we should stop
asking ourselves what the european union
can do for us but what we can do for the
european union
president
thank you very much madam president
prime minister hi representative war has
come back to haunt europe death is
knocking at our door and we need to live
up to the challenges despite our efforts
and the heroism of the ukrainian people
we have not been able to stop the war
and we still
cannot stop it
we have done a lot in very little time
we have put in place
sanctions against the russian regime we
have tried to stop propaganda from the
russian government and we have delivered
weapons to ukraine but we see that this
is not enough we need to do more to
defend the ukrainian people and to
defend ourselves
we need to
[Music]
use less
oil and russian
gas we need to provide more weapons to
ukraine not to prolong the conflict but
so that it can
protect its civilians who are being
bombed by the russians
we also need to
help moldova which is
taking in many many refugees and they're
very concerned that they will be putin's
next target we need to protect ourselves
by making significant efforts to improve
our
defense spending
germany is increasing its military
budget good it was high time
denmark wants to join
a europe of defense also good but
there's still a lot to be done
military mobility has not made enough
progress our critical infrastructures
are not yet sufficiently protected we
need to strengthen the solidarity
amongst european countries
i welcome the reinforcement of nato's
presence to the east but we also need to
look to those countries that are not
part of the atlantic alliance yet i'm
thinking particularly of sweden and
finland here
europe is going to adopt its strategic
compass so let us not hesitate let us
make every effort possible to build a
european union of defense
it will
not come too soon we have spoke of this
for a long long time and hopefully it
will not be too late now
next on behalf of the greens at scale
thank you president prime minister
the war putin is waging
is targeted against ukraine shelling
civilian areas and attacking refugees
but his wars also meant against europe
as a whole
putin intends to destroy the post-cold
war european security architecture putin
is waging a war against democracy rule
of law and freedoms
which are universal values
as european union as union built for
peace
we must act for the european security
at european level we need to make sure
that the member states defense is
functioning
that investments are compatible with one
another that pooling and sharing finally
gets implemented and that we have common
standards so equipment cannot be used by
one state alone
but colleagues
if we are exclusively thinking about the
army when saying defense and security
then we don't see the whole picture
security means much more
it means energy security and energy
independence
we need to get rid of the dependence on
russia's fossil fuels and raw materials
be it gas
oil coal or uranium we have plenty of
sun and wind to use on our own we have
the technology at hand
we need to reduce our consumption and
speed up fit for 55 investing massively
in renewables in energy efficiency and
in energy saving
security also means civil protection
in the last years and decades much of
the protective infrastructure in europe
has been neglected
floods and wildfires in the recent years
have already shown us the lack of
preparedness the eu and its member
states need to urgently work on how to
protectively protect
how to effectively protect citizens
security also means to make sure that
europe's critical infrastructure is well
functioning well stocked and in public
hands
the same goes for the cyber security and
our digital infrastructure and data
we need to talk about resilient
societies about communities that help
each other and are educated to withstand
misinformation campaigns and to spot
fake news
and security for europe means solidarity
among member states about sharing the
efforts for example for welcoming the
many people fleeing ukraine
they need to be housed they need medical
care the children need to go to school
and that will need a shared effort by
all member states and not just a few
we have seen it in the last two weeks
when we act together we are strong
this is the lesson that we have to carry
forward thank you
thank you very much ms keller
i give the floor next to jack madison on
behalf of the id group
thank you so much
mrs president
i started in english and now i continue
in english way that if i listen to our
good colleagues from the socialist group
and from the iranian group
if they are calling for more military
help to ukraine
that's exactly what we have to do i've
heard some kind of arguments that if we
help
in a military way ukraine
then the war would be bigger it will be
more cows
it will be a disaster in the world it
will be a third world war but no
the sooner we end the war in ukraine
the sooner the russia will be back in
their own territory and the sooner those
refugees who are really refugees today
women and children are escaping from war
zone to neighborhood countries the
sooner they can go back their homes
i just read yesterday that our good
colleagues from poland they are ready to
help ukraine with the fighter jets
that's what we have to do and
unfortunately when i was reading our
good colleagues from the us
now they are scared
they are not ready
to really move those fighter jets
through nato bases to ukraine
but every day the russians are just
killing the ordinary people they are
killing the children they are attacking
hospitals they are attacking like
ordinary houses
and every day what we are waiting
with the help
the more the disaster will be
and if they will be succeed
russians in ukraine that's the question
who's next
we have seen in the last three months
they're ambitious we have seen what they
have told and their dream is to go back
to the soviet union time and
unfortunately well i'm and also miss
scalas are from the country
who's very close to russia and it's very
easy to close baltic states from the
western world
and that's why we have to stop the war
as soon as possible and harmfully
against russians
also i would like to mention that
we have to understand that there has
been huge support from the russian
population to putin
luke of 2014 after the crimean election
there was a huge support to go to crimea
and to occupy it so that's why i
wouldn't say that there is totally
different parts of russia that there is
putin and kremlin and there are ordinary
people
that large part of the russians are
fortunately still supporting this
aggressor
and i would like to conclude in estonia
i'm addressing myself to mrs gallas
because i don't meet her very often
nato is an important ally for us so
there's no doubt about that but in order
for the allies to be able to defend us
we must do our bit as well
uh political consensus in estonia is
that we must invest uh as uh quickly as
possible into national defense we have
to take a loan to do that um
uh at at the moment we have a lowest
foreign debt in the eu
um
at the moment there is war going on in
our neighboring country
uh we we must take this load but there
is only one uh estonian political party
that is against it and this is the
reform party your own party you say that
uh it will threaten the balance of the
budget uh today we shouldn't speak about
the balance of a budget we should speak
about investing in our defense
capabilities all other parties agree
even social democrats let's defend
ukraine let's defend europe but also
estonia
president madam prime minister
high rep vice president
we used to call the soviet union
the empire of evil
and
the prison of nations
now
looking listening to news after
bloody
awful
full-scale
cruel aggression of russian federation
on ukraine
we feel unbearable the javi
once more willing to call it
like this
ukrainian
fight
what we call
bellum eustom
a war that is just because with war arms
in their hands
they
defend their territory
whole territory
internationally recognized territory
they defend their families
innocent civilians
against an enemy against war crimes
against crimes against humanity because
we see traces of this not only traces
actually already many documented
cases
unfortunately future security of our
continent
and probably global security very much
depends on the result of this war
and therefore
we have to do our at most
to stop it
how to respond
proportionately madam president
to killings of innocent
children 18 months old
and and
how to to use strategic patient
when we have this kind of of results
the only way i i see
is
after a surrender
of russian federation
full rejections of
imperialist ambitions
of will and that is not only putin
that's sure
the will
to to stay aggressive vis-a-vis
neighbors and and much more beyond
we have to work to to this end thank you
next is next is martin shirdowan on
behalf of the left group
thank you very much
madam president
welcome
madam prime minister
the
attack on ukrainian violation of
international law has
shocked and dismayed many
people in europe and in the world they
were afraid that this war could
spread and escalate to a
conflict between
nuclear powers we have to do everything
in our power to stop this happening and
to ensure that this war in the heart of
europe is ended without delay the
peace in europe
is destroyed by
every grenade by every air raid by every
bullet that is fired and our global
security architecture is
shaken to the core vladimir putin is
responsible fully responsible for this
without any ifs or buts and i have to
say that this cowardly attack against
ukraine has caught into question my own
political views and obliges me to look
for new answers but where there can be
no doubt
but just one unambiguous response is as
to our solidarity and our empathy with
the ukrainian population who are living
through an appalling tragedy
and my thoughts are also with those
courageous russian citizens who are not
only opposed to the war but who are
putting themselves in great personal
danger in order to demonstrate against
the increasingly dictatorial rule of
putin
effective sanctions
are necessary against putin and his
oligarchs
only if you hit the apparatus of power
around putin will you be able to weaken
his
power base so let's confiscate those
yachts and villas let's
track down that dirty money and
make them available for humanitarian aid
and to rebuild the destroyed cities in
ukraine
but for these targeted sanctions to
really hit home there has to be an end
to the possibility of oligarchs uh
parking their
wealth in eu
in eu tax havens we need a strong tax
transparency property registers and a
strict regulation of crypto currencies
in the long term
the eu will only be able to pay play a
credible role in the global security
architecture
if it can supply its own energy needs
and renewable energy has to be
extended and built up we also need a
sustainable
food sovereignty we need
our own autonomy and public control for
critical infrastructure like the
semiconductor industry for
health health sector and also for public
services ladies and gentlemen there will
come a day
when this terrible war is over and
although many certainties are being
called into question these days one
conviction remains intact and that is
that the world
will not be a safer place through more
armament and more military
use of military force if we want to
offer our children a peaceful future we
have to take cons concrete steps to
disarm and to strengthen international
organizations to put an end to weapons
of mass destruction and we will have to
work on a security architecture that is
based on international law and that
allows for conflicts to be resolved
peacefully through diplomacy thank you
floor next on behalf of the non-attached
members to king again
and we are faced with russia's
aggression against the ukraine
this is a big challenge
we
understand that nato does not want to
become directly involved
in
this war we
need strategic calm
we need to avoid any steps that would
bring
our country uh hungary uh into danger
we
see
war coming to our borders
there
we are showing a lot of solidarity from
our side to
the ukrainians this is the most aid
hungary has ever provided
we do not accept the criticism that has
been levelled at hungary saying that we
have not shown solidarity
colleagues
the security situation in europe today
depends on one thing
and one thing only
whether we stay strong and united and
defeat the 21st century hitler and
stalin in one called putin
whether we defeat him is up to us
yesterday a ukrainian writer oksana
zabushka said
ukrainians are not afraid of russia the
ukrainians will defend their land
what about us
is the european union afraid of russia
are we afraid of high costs
all of us we have to say no
now the key questions for ourselves are
first
full military assistance to the
ukrainians currently defending europe
second full containment of the putin
regime and russia to the point of total
embargo
fed sanctions until the very end
until the last occupier leaves the
ukrainian soil
all of its territory fourth a special
procedure for ukraine's eu candidate
status now ukraine signed its membership
application in blood
where i call on the council not to be
afraid of russia and of this challenge
to ourselves
ukraine needs political protection slavo
ukraine
thank you
nexus pedro marcus
thank you very much president prime
minister
high representative
colleagues
the war has brought us atrocities
that infiltrate our own lives through
our economy
it's the fuels in our cars the meat on
our tables
but let's not allow the economic
consequences
to weaken our resolve
that would be a failure of solidarity
and that we could never pardon ourselves
now it's a question of a fight for
freedom the freedom of ukrainians today
may be our own tomorrow so it's
important that the eu should act rapidly
before this war turns into a deep
crisis
so we need rapid action
and it's not just a question of next
generation eu because that money is
required to fulfill the investment gap
in the eu we need a next generation eu
2.0
we need to show that same level of
ambition that we showed in combating
covid
because this
puts the union in jeopardy
high representative dear colleagues
putin's plan to steadily expand
aggressive ruski mir has turned into a
brutal war against ukraine a human
tragedy and become a litmus test for the
eu and the west in general
let us recognize that ukraine is a
welcome candidate to our family let us
help to repel aggressor and let give us
the all support they need
let us provide a safe haven for
ukrainian women children and elderly
people who are forced to flee
we have no right
to let cerebral niza happen again
we must do everything possible to return
the sky over ukraine to a peaceful blue
and to make the evacuation of civilians
safe let us create
an eu civilian force
that can ensure the safety of evacuation
at short noticed colleagues no fly zone
no europe zone
the european union's response to the
aggression against ukraine must be based
on a principle
collective victory
or collective failure
and i believe
only the later is not a choice long live
european ukraine thank you thank you
very very much
next is jordi soleil
thank you madam president madam prime
minister
representative
was definitely right when he wrote in
his memoirs europe will be forged in
crisis the u.s response to the terrible
crisis provoked by putin's invasion of
ukraine ukraine has been swift united
and strong
it's an answer that lives up to the
seriousness of the moment the worst
security crisis in europe since the end
of the second world war
and it has allowed us eu citizens to
feel convinced that by helping ukraine
in almost every way we can we are
defending as well the pillars of our
common european house
whether this determination will lead to
you to become finally a geopolitical
player this is still to be seen we have
progress a lot in just a few days it's
true but there is still much more to be
done much more convergence in foreign
and security policy to be achieved
what is for sure is that use response
has been one of the many miscalculations
of putin he expected the usual disunity
and bake diplomatic jargon but he has
got instead unprecedented sanctions for
his regime and unprecedented solidarity
with ukraine
it is now of utmost importance that the
u.s unity and solidarity holds in the
event of a prolonged war and even when
the economic reverberations of the world
start start hitting our economies our
unity will be key to make putin and this
his bloody war and while decisive
protest in shaping our own security and
defense is to be expected in the months
to come we must not forget or relinquish
the role that real diplomacy will have
to regain at some point in this painful
conflict thank you the sooner the better
we will also have to be ready to play a
key role in that thank you very much
next is mara bizzotto
thank you president the war in ukraine
is a dramatic act of madness
putin's military operation against the
ukraine
it has to be stopped absolutely and as
soon as possible using the arms of
diplomacy to re-establish peace
this is a dirty war that is causing
death and destruction among the civilian
population and it threatens to
destabilize the whole world the war in
ukraine is
one that affects all of us because it's
an attack on the values of the whole of
the free west
putin's threat is a threat to peace
around the world to our security
and we cannot pretend that nothing is
happening here
with every means available to us we have
to defend our freedom and our democracy
this has to be our mission when faced
with a global threat which is arriving
from dictatorships and regimes like
communist china this islamic
dictatorships or putin's russia to rise
to this challenge we must be united we
have to have a strong alliance with the
united states of america
it's time for us to reinforce the
atlantic alliance we need to build a
solid alliance with israel it's high
time that we created a special
relationship with the great britain and
the countries of the anglo-sphere they
are important to our common security and
defence policy
europe has to accept its share of the
guilt for ambiguity
in the past
colleagues the war in ukraine is a
historical crossroads
where on one hand you have western
democracy and freedom and on the other
you have the
dictatorship and violence we stand side
by side with ukrainian people
we need to ensure that peace puts an end
to these bombs and let's hope that
liberty will prevail over dictatorship
madam president
prime minister
high representative
sanctions real sanctions
yes but without exceptions
russia
is
a
exporting
arms and natural resources
and
if we
impose sanctions
with exceptions then it's going to be a
gift to put in and it's going to be
a feigned
solidarity
tomorrow
there will be
talks between ukraine and
russia in turkey
um
we could not influence those talks
perhaps we could influence more
u.n talks if any uh
nice metaphor on the european uh garden
and the jungle outside but in the
beautiful
garden we didn't always have solidarity
some countries next to the jungle
were attacked
so i would expect
that you promised there will be no
attacks
on countries that are next to the jungle
i also hope
that finland will take the right
decision on
nato
now one very important thing
uh
common uh nato efforts and no individual
is next for one and a half minutes
prime minister
we have to condemn war started by russia
it's a dirty war against an innocent
country and civilians suffer the most we
have to be prepared to take
refugees from ukraine we have to make
sure that sanctions remain in place and
be
united and strong many member countries
think about new strategies in the new
uh security situation as ukraine all
sovereign states has have
their right to take their sovereign
decisions independently in terms of
security policy
they have to be taken independently
without any pressure and their aim
always has to be peace we have to
fight for peace we have to provide
humanitarian support and at the same
time we have to get rid of
russian oil and gas this is necessary
not only for security but also for
environment and economy commissions
report yesterday was a good start but we
can do more we have to launch green
investments in order to
make sure that green transition will
take place soon we need new strategies
for warming up houses and using
renewable energy sources we need new
investments in europe they also create
jobs we have to launch them immediately
if this requires new funding mechanisms
we have to be prepared for that thank
you
for one minute
thank you president prime minister high
representative
the choice of arming ukraine and
disproportionately
worsening the sanctions against
russia are going to have an excessive
impact
i think that
there will inevitably be consequences
for the european economy
european companies are paying for the
short-sighted policies decided upon by
the uh commission and the price is high
prices of commodities are going very
high and the impact is uh being felt on
uh consumer prices as well we're now in
a situation where thousands of companies
could go bankrupt poverty could increase
social tensions could
worsen
this is not going to be the impact on
russia this is going to be the impact on
europe
this disaster cannot simply be blamed on
putin because it's
caused by mistaken choices by european
governments if we try and solve this
with more arms more uh sanctions etc
well it's easy to be heroic with other
people's lives
we need to ensure that our defense and
security
is uh
promoted genuinely
well it's the objective though to create
a european army financed by european
taxpayers no
madam president ladies and gentlemen
the barbaric attack
against ukraine as many previous
speakers have said
is a decisive moment
we have seen how the world has changed
over the last decade since the 90s now
we as europeans need to learn to fight
again for our values
we need to preserve our
security our freedom and so
if we want to preserve these we need a
reality check
we need a new focus for our
foreign and defense policy
we need to make
this policy more effective the european
parliament with a large majority for
years has made
proposals has debated this
there were two reports recently adopted
here in strasbourg so let us finally
take tangible measures to move forward
to a
european union of defense working
closely with our nato partners thank you
very much
next is marek
[Applause]
high representative
how many children will your war take
okay an lc is an ukrainian band singing
this song well war has come back to
europe it's knocking on our doors
sanctions and help have shown the eu as
a strong bloc
which will not only stand by and look
stand by and look at the conflict at its
borders
our sanctions
throw away russia from the
community of nations we need more
sanctions that would devastate the
russian economy these sanctions must
hurt
they must hurt putin the oligarchs but
also unfortunately the citizens of
russia
why because social tension and rebellion
revolution in russia can prevent further
crimes
will these sanctions hurt us as well
yes we hope that the commission will
present a strategy to contain the
consequences of these sanctions but this
is a price to pay for the defense of our
values
we
have to make sure that there is there
are no tears
on the faces of the ukrainians and the
europeans thank you
it was just two weeks ago when we woke
up
to war
in the heart of europe russia has
wrenched peace out of place for two
weeks now ukraine has been resisting
heroically and its population has been
suffering the horrors of war europe has
shown that it can act quickly and with
determination and that is a ray of hope
and putin didn't expect that level of
resolve but now colleagues we have to
show stamina for the long term we
shouldn't budge an inch before putin and
we have to support ukraine in the long
term economically with humanitarian aid
and with the weapons we have to
meticulously implement the sanctions
we've decided close any loopholes and we
have to use any possibility of ending
our dependence on russian energy not one
single euro should go into putin's war
chest
we have to turn off the money supply
europe has to set itself as a bastion of
law and
freedom we have to build up our
capabilities militarily in full
complementarity with nato economically
with a view to building the resilience
of our economy and politically by
defending together
freedom democracy and the rule of law
and with regard to china we must show
unity peaking has to decide uh whether
it wishes to be a partner or an opponent
of the free world there is still time
for china to act as a peace broker and
to be on the right side of history
[Applause]
the prime minister high representative
president
the world that wars is no more it
changed irreversible when putin's troops
crossed the ukrainian border and started
killing civilians
putin did exactly what some of us have
been warning you about for years
yet i don't feel pleasure for saying i
told you so it's no time for pointing
fingers it's time to stand up for
ukraine and bolster our security
putin's bloody war has shaken us to the
core
now we need to protect our democracy
and our union by all means
many things we considered unthinkable
happened
north stream 2 is stopped russia is
partly cut off from swift eu's member
states defense budget increased
significantly this means that we can act
and adapt and face of danger
regardless of how russian invasion ends
putin has already lost this war he
turned his country into a perea state
and destroyed its economy
modern russia is not the military
superpower as claimed by putin its
imperial ambitions will be forever
buried under ukrainian rasboost
it is not a war only against ukraine
this is putin's war against the
civilized world ukraine on the front
line is defending us and every democracy
we cannot let ukraine fall we need to
support our fellow europeans with all
resources they require in their defence
war
thank you thank you very much i give the
floor next to harald wilmski
thank you
very much ladies and gentlemen
i think we're saber-rattling far too
much when i listen to the previous
speakers
what
the uh
russian regime and putin have
done
is of course to be condemned war is
never a solution
but the way that we react here in
parliament i think is simply pouring
fuel onto the fire it is not the correct
way forward
let me just give you some examples
involving nato
further is simply a sign that we don't
want peace we are escalating the
situation
having
ukraine on a fast track to join the eu
that's also the wrong direction forward
do they how many more european criteria
are you just going to throw overboard
schengen maastricht
uh the copenhagen criteria none of this
seems to mean anything anymore when we
look at the european framework and
thirdly this issue of sanctions
it's not the wanderlines or the
bidens
it is
the
people
who are
suffering who now have to pay such high
prices at the petrol pump we need to
de-escalate
and we need to choose the right weight
forward to
ukraine
you no longer have the floor patreon
ronson you have the floor next
high representative
the war in ukraine
has brought us brutally face to face
with the facts
war in europe
that was all in the past
investing in defence
there was no need for all that
thought a great many people
now we know better
we need to change course that much is
clear
no not by creating new
european command structures let alone a
european army
but
through increasing military cooperation
and coordination between member states
for our defence we already have an
excellent system for cooperation and
that is the nato alliance
let us invest in that and cherish that
and
it's now up to european
member states to shoulder responsibility
we need more money a great deal more
money
finally
germany
has woken up with its injection of 100
billion
in its defense
but what about the rest there is a
reason why nato recommends two percent
of gnp going into defence russia is a
big danger to world peace
that's what we have to arm ourselves
against
ivan vili boris in church for one minute
thank you
we hear a lot of accusations from
ukraine even from its presidents that we
have left them out to hang
and
we keep
hearing on the other side
words of encouragement
but now the west is not doing anything
because it does not want to risk the
third world war wasn't the same
situation with
previous cases
where
russia intervened
in gruesia
and
west
is prepared only for sanctions
we are ready to sanction the vodka and
swift and to sanction tchaikovsky and
dostoyevsky and all of these things have
very little to do with the war but
serious sanctions such as
oil and gas
here we are very restricted and the west
continues financing russia i also have
to mention the latest information that
appeared in the us and chinese media
about dozens of biological laboratories
in ukraine
directly controlled by the us ministry
of defense i would like to have it
clarified what is there what is being
developed there because we do not need
another wuhan thank you
thank you very much madam president
prime minister high representative thank
you very much for being present with us
today i think that europe has to emerge
stronger from every crisis and i think
that that's what we're seeing after this
illegal and barbaric war that russia has
launched against ukraine ukraine
we need a united europe
we have to defend our own territories of
course and we have to do that at
any price we need a strong europe with a
strong role a europe that intervenes to
defend peace
that's why
what we need today
is a genuine debate about resources for
defence
so that we can have common european
measures
so that we can protect and defend
europe's borders when they are
threatened
putin has probably
thought through a number of different
scenarios
he can prevail militarity militarily but
his job is being made very difficult by
a ukrainian resistance
europe has to
have its voice heard loud and clear we
need defense resources to defend the
free democratic countries and to do that
with all
available means this war has to be
expensive for him
thank you prime minister president
the war led by russian president putin
marks a turning point in recent european
history russian aggression has provoked
a tectonic shift in the eu and this is
the only good to come out of the tragic
events of the past two weeks
the eu 27 member states can agree on a
position they can act unified as a
geopolitical actor on the world stage
europe's common foreign and security
policy must not remain the weakest link
in the chain of european integration
european security cannot be defined
outside the eu the union must finally
take greater responsibility for its
security and defense and prevent what
happened to vukovar and srebrenica
it is high time to increase investment
in defense and strengthen strategic
autonomy europe should be a leader in
establishing a new multilateral agenda
let us use this momentum to turn our
ambition into concrete actions our
citizens expectations are clear
strengthening our common defense is a
priority for them and the ep should be
included as an equal partner
madam president prime minister high
representative
putin believed there would be no
ukrainian resistance and he was mistaken
he thought the 27 member states would
not react and he was wrong he believed
that the americans would not act and he
was wrong
he believed that the russians
would back him and he was wrong
he has been wrong on every
count
and there is only one last point where
we need to prove him wrong
mr putin now needs to understand that
our nations are
willing
to resist him
through
abandoning use of russian gas we need to
call on all 27 member states to no
longer buy oil or gas and to close
ukrainian skies to mr putin we need to
show
the willingness of the eu to resist this
war of aggression that threatens all of
our continent
it is up to the 27
governments of the member states to see
when and how to do this but knowing
that
they can count on us for our
determination and our support when it
comes to the necessary discussions
thank you
next is bronies rope for one minute
thank you madam president prime minister
high representatives colleagues with
putin waging the war i hope now we have
all learned to listen more attentively
to warnings
the baltic states have long been issuing
warnings about the kremlin's plans
second
we are still learning but our reaction
to challenges has accelerated as was
shown by speed activation of sanctions
third we have learned that only acting
in global partnership with other
countries we can achieve tangible
results i hope that now we understand
that empty words about the autonomy of
the european union change nothing
we need to act and our actions should be
targeted and quick
madam prime minister how many chances do
we have that the council
will
decide on
quitting on
diffusal for fossil from
prime minister
high representative ladies and gentlemen
it is a time
of trial a time of responsibility and
solidarity of the union as a whole
and
the world
as a whole
we are confronting
an aggressor and we must stop him
and we must support ukraine because it's
about our
security
in europe
so
it's time
to stop the lip service and it's time to
act
and we must also
mention uh
what we need to do because it is also
our responsibility the parliament and
the commission
we cannot allow
uh
the situation when
uh poland uh like estonia
is
um
helping ukrainians all families in
poland are receiving
uh the refugees
poland
is being
punished
including in this house and there will
be another attempt against
to adopt a resolution against poland
today the obvious for one minute
thank you brazilian
our duty is to help ukraine because they
are suffering an intolerable regression
and because the principles of the
international system must be upheld
territory of integrity no invasions are
allowed to change borders their right to
self-determination and third we believe
in solving conflicts through democratic
means
so the eu has reacted
but more is needed
military aid
must be sped up let's not hesitate war
crimes are being committed we must help
the refugees more and better
we need to stop energy imports from
russia
and broaden sanctions the eu is leading
in sanctions against the oligarchs but
that's not enough sanctions must also
target the bureaucrats and the higher
equivalence of the russian state we must
extend our pressure to the allies of
putin those who promote autocracy at our
borders and also inside the eu we have
awakened let's show that we can be
better thank you very much i give the
floor next to andre halitsky for one
minute
ladies and gentlemen yes this is a time
for a historic test for us because this
war concerns us it's about the future of
europe this future will be decided in
ukraine
so we cannot be just a little bit on the
side of ukraine and to pay putin a
little bit
for arming this terrorist terrorist army
which is killing murdering civilians in
ukraine murdering children
we must show
full
solidarity and full consistency
interactions and embargo on gas coal oil
because we cannot give even one euro to
putin who is a terrorist his place is in
the hague he should be tried there and
we should show solidarity and unity
because there are helpers putin's
helpers in this room who want to weaken
the sanctions and this and dismantle
europe
future uh europe must be um safe so it
must be also consistent and uh show
solidarity ukrainians need our
solidarity those mothers those children
need our help so i call upon you to
finance these people they really need
our help thank you
sir for one minute
madam president prime minister what
transpired on the 24th of february was
shocking but not surprising
in fact canaries in the coal mine have
been singing about these threats all
along
but it was a watershed and we have
changed in those two weeks
now we have to make those changes
sustainable we have to do six things
first of all of course we have to deny
putin a victory in ukraine
and show to the world that ultimately
would
triumph over evil secondly we have to
strategically weaken the russian
dictatorship any threat consists of two
vectors the intent to do harm and the
ability to do so
we cannot expect to change putin's evil
intent so we simply have to remove his
ability
thirdly we have to boost our defenses
including defence spending
fourth we have to boost our resilience
including the resilience of liberal
democracy itself
fifth we have to reduce our dependencies
of authoritarian countries like russia
in strategic areas and finally we have
to build alliances
the maxim
together with our allies whenever we can
alone only if we really must is still
very much valid especially in
existential crisis like this one thank
you thank you very much mr mix and
access giver hofstadt for one minute
so thank you for your leadership uh
prime minister um
let's uh let's tell it here in the house
uh
estonia was one
uh of the first country if not even the
first country to send weaponry to
ukraine and you are showing that in
these dramatic
circumstances
smaller countries in our union count
and
can lead by example so thank you very
much for that
but for the rest let's not pat ourselves
on the back the sad reality
their colleagues is that we are not
doing enough for ukraine today
is a no-fly zone is not on the radar
our financial sanctions are only
targeting seven banks
russian banks that's 30
of the russian banking sector
and most importantly there is still no
ban on russian oil and gas
ukraine is fighting for european values
and for our democracies while we
europeans continue to finance the war
machine of putin
the evil
so in my opinion
it's time that
after the americas and the british also
we decide on a full temporary ban on
russian oil and gas as long as this
aggression is continuing that is what we
need to do
and yes we will suffer
but we will survive in the coming months
but it is not clear
if the ukrainians will survive in the
coming months if we don't take that
decision and we don't need
mr borrell it's not to you that i'm
telling that to the commission in
general a fantastic strategic paper to
lower
our dependency to russian gas now that's
for later what we need now is immediate
action and a decision on the european
level to ban
a temporary ban until the end of the war
of russian oil and gas thank you very
much
i give the floor next to mr brzezinski
for one minute
thank you very much madam president
prime minister i'd like to thank for
your
voice of
uh political realism
we
the citizens of central europe we must
speak with realistic voice
and we are those that have long
experience with living
with russia
russia's always wanted to
impose its powers on its neighbors and
therefore
this is how it ends
in 2008
the then
uh
polish
president said today
um
georgia then ukraine and then perhaps
poland
in a western europe uh you said that it
was uh an exaggeration when we started
the building of uh gaza port uh in
schweinsteiger the germany said that it
was a wrong decision today
local
authorities in mecklenburg refuse
to accept
refugees because
they are afraid of their interests
so if
member states continue with this policy
putin will continue to murder innocent
ukrainians we ma may stop putin with
solidarity
for one minute
thanks very much madam president prime
minister welcome back to the european
parliament four points from my side
firstly thank you prime minister for
everything that yourself and estonia has
been doing in support of ukraine estonia
was one of the first countries to
understand the importance of
developments in ukraine to help ukraine
even before the invasion i feel that
estonia understands that defending
ukraine means defending europe second
point prime minister i believe you can
continue helping us very much by
explaining to the world what the russian
federation is doing your insights the
experience of the estonian people are
very important you have witnessed the
provocations of the russian federations
you understand their actions better you
know their vulnerabilities i believe
that explaining this to europe and to
the world from your side and the side of
the baltic countries is very important
thirdly i also believe that we should
stop buying russian gas because buying
russian gas means
financing putin's war it makes us weaker
in terms of security and fourthly we
have to do more together use the
economies of scale that means that we
will make our armies more modern uh
cheaper and we will be able to more
modern more innovative cheaper we will
be able to do more and better defend
ourselves with the same resources we
have to spend more on defense we should
start doing more on security and defense
and keep that because we now understood
russia is the threat and russia will
continue to be a threat thank you very
much thank you very much mr murasan i
give the floor next to kathleen van
brampt for one minute
mr president
mrs prime minister dear kaya
can i also first give my deep respect
and appreciation um for what you do you
come from a very small country
and in this case a very vulnerable
country um and um and you take sound
political leadership in the eu thank you
very much for that mr colleague
colleagues the first phase of this war
um didn't turn out the way putin
expected uh the ukrainian population is
more determined than ever
and um
the russians are demonstrating on the
street the international community has
showed unity but
still the hardest part is still to come
putin wanted to divide people in ukraine
and also wanted to break the unity of
europe so the only answer to this is to
stand together shoulder to shoulder in
solidarity and i think we should do this
by
radically uh
stopping the supply of oil and gas to
europe and in doing this we must show
solidarity we need to support ukraine
with
money and humanitarian aid and we have
to show the european population that
however difficult it may be we can do it
together
europe will respond with unity
solidarity and trust
fight for one minute
dear colleagues dear prime minister i am
very happy that
it is the estonian prime minister who
stands before the european parliament
today
she has
done a lot in expressing european
principles
but
in ukraine
dozens of children have been killed and
hundreds have been injured the
inhabitants of mario paul and other
cities are trapped under russian
bombings bombings over two million
refugees most of them women with
children all of this is affecting europe
and all of it will continue as long as
putin's regime keeps up the killing in
ukraine
the refugees need humanitarian corridors
now we need to give ukraine anything it
needs as it defends itself from aircraft
and other weapons to food and medication
european money paid for gas and oil must
not end up financing the russian war
machine
the free world can guarantee all of this
to help ukraine push back the aggressor
putin's regime has bombed itself out of
today's europe
the eu
should also rio reassess its position
towards countries that approve of
russia's war in ukraine
i could see a spot opening up for
ukraine to become a candidate country
for estonia being a member of the eu and
nato is a natural state of affairs in
the current world the same opportunity
needs to be awarded to other european
nations ukraine first and foremost so
that we would never again hear ukrainian
woman escaping her homeland with her
children say through tears i had no
other choice
he would give the floor next to mihal
gala for one minute
for president midfield
madam president
together with
many uh colleagues since 2015 i spoke
out against nordstrom 2.
now
it wasn't just about
the issues with ukraine
i
have
long spoken out about
sending
weapons to ukraine it's not good to have
a weakened country next to russia
i think what we need to do
is to really do everything we can with
sanctions to have a full energy
boycott
we do we are seeing uh carpet bombing as
we did in aleppo or grozny
i think
we have to understand the price
is higher
energy prices but i think every citizen
can turn down their heating by two
degrees so we can
help stop the dictator in the kremlin
before i give the floor to the next
speaker i will open the first voting
session of today which will be open
until quarter to two and the results
will be announced this evening at seven
uh nicholas andrew luck is next for one
minute
there's no spring this year for the
children of ukraine putin's invasion is
an illegal and barbaric act against the
whole of humanity it plunges an entire
people into destruction and despair
this takes us back to what we thought
was an ugly and distant past
the european states are so committed to
their economies that they have uh
underestimated the uh autocrats like
putin and erdogan
tragically
this is a new era that is opening
the union has to equip itself against
these terrible tyrants
the single foreign and defense policy
and energy autonomy are top priorities
the uh idea of a european army joint
armament program strong economic
sanctions the arms embargo these are
tools that can safeguard
prosperity and borders from finland and
estonia to greece and cyprus i do not
want europe to return to militarism
though
we should not allow militarism to return
that is our duty
we have to do everything possible to
avoid that
thanks madam president madame prime
minister mr burrell thanks very much
both of you for your leadership
but let me ask a question dear
colleagues
are we doing enough
to help ukrainians
the sad answer is no true we are in the
ukrainians madame prime minister you
talked about the half a billion
uh peace facility but the truth is that
we're spending
many more resources arming putting
today every day we are sending one
billion euros to pay for our oil and gas
etc to put in
why
our leaders tell us that we might fall
in a recession
if we stop doing that
come on dear colleagues that hypocrisy
has to stop
the moral strategic arguments of not
harming our enemies are obvious but so
are the economic arguments our economies
will suffer much more as a result of
slow slowly escalating and long-lasting
war that we bankrupt putting now
if we make it impossible for him to pay
wages pensions and the salaries of his
military prime minister carlos mr
burrell let's buy the bullet now not
buying russian gas is bearable for our
economies what is unbearable is
continuing to pay for putin's murders
thank you very much thank you very much
mr gary kano i give the floor next to
rehotels for one minute
thank you madam president
madam prime minister
tia kaya
thank you very much being with us in
this time cycle today and i also want to
join the people who
have thanked you for your leadership in
this very difficult times
i certainly agree with the assumption
that we are in the in this for a long
haul
that makes us responsible of making the
right decisions today
that demands from us a committing
adequate resources and building up
european pillar of defense together with
nato
this pillar must not be an oversized
construct
or an empty password
but well-funded and coordinated effort
which means
if not today
when then we should reach the two
percent of minimum of defence spending
he will overall europe
but
at the moment
we need to act
as one to paralyze putin
full embargo and the deepest cuts
against aggression
combined with maximum military support
air defense
planes
to ukraine
thank you
thank you very much mr terrace i give
the floor next to me a petra kumpulana
three for one minute
president uh and welcome to the european
parliament the prime minister of
neighboring country the acaia
finland and estonia we share the same
external border with the russia the
country has brutally alone attacked
ukraine
we share historical memories too
when sweden now decided for the center
military equipment to russia it was
first time since 1939 when they helped
finland in the winter war
and
be sure that we discussed now several
proposals to and strengthen the union
and strengthen our security and this is
done in the democratic way
new era brutally started in 24 february
by russia our sanctions were not enough
and actions were not enough after
occupation of crimea and now we see a
attack against democratic rules based
system against innocent civilians and
two past weeks shows we have not pushed
enough sanctions attacks on ukraine is
not only concern of sovereign state but
horrifying fact that war is in europe
and the concern is also the whole
humanity it is important to see that
crossing the border breaking the rules
also hand causes and icc is opening
investigation on the alleged war crimes
and crimes against humanity in ukraine
eu has been leading now and
transatlantic relations are very
important to be so and dear president in
this same very room we will have an
opportunity this weekend to build a
better uh more secure europe by the
citizens and for the citizens when we
talk in the future conference thank you
mr petra thank you neil storvaltz is
next for one minute
but i'm president
uh welcome back to the european
parliament
uh only in a different
i
capacity
had flashbacks
from my years as a correspondent in
russia
i covered the first war in chechnya
and i saw the catastrophic results
of a morally decay in the russian army
and then morally decayed or derailed
army is something very very dangerous
and we see the same political decay
inside the walls of kremlin
today with tragic results for ukraine
for the young men for the mothers and
the children
we see the result of this morally
catastrophic catastrophe
who wanted this
if you use the words of jeff duchenkus
poem
there is a sentence
saying that ask the soldiers under the
birches
and their sons will answer
the russians
don't want the war
the one who's wanting it
is mr vladimir vladimirov putin
let us make this his last wish
thank you thank you very much
mr torvalds i give the floor next to
paulo ranjel for one minute
dear president
high representative
modern prime minister you have just said
your mother taught you
that saying
i told you was rather impolite
it may be unpolite
and it won't change the past but it can
be very useful
i hope
that today everybody in this house
and every leader in european union
has heard you and has listened to your
advice your proposals and your views
then we won't need any more to say i
told you
exposed the response that we have to
give to vladimir putin has to be
a clear response
it is high time now
for us
to stop buying gas and oil from russia
the next european council an informal
council
has to take that step
it will mean sacrifices it will mean
economic losses
but it's the only way we can avoid
financing putin's war
it's the only way to avoid financing the
destruction of ukraine thank you
well i give the floor next to rafael
glucksman for one minute
thank you madam president thank you and
i'm prime minister for your leadership
museum
live near the laura
the future of europe will be decided in
the ruins of
and mariopol in odessa if we do not stop
putin in ukraine we will no longer know
peace in our continent
we might not intervene militarily but we
can do a lot more than we're doing today
each day we
are
financing putin's war machine to the
tune of around 600 million
our imports of oil and gas allow putin
to destroy schools and hospitals it is
time to put an end to this
yes this decision will be costly for our
nations but the member states have a way
to
mitigate these effects
whatever it costs it is worth it for
peace and freedom in europe if the cost
of inaction is high
then
i think we can assume that cost
what
cost
would you be prepared to pay for your
freedom and your sovereignty what is the
response we can bring collectively to
this our answer is dependent on the
future of ukraine i give the floor next
to francis comey and moon for one minute
thank you madam president
with the russian attack on ukraine
we find ourselves in a new geopolitical
situation
russia has decided to openly become an
enemy that ignores our values and
launches a war
on our eastern flank we have a cruel
adversary who doesn't accept
international law and is threatening to
use nuclear weapons
for the european union i think the
lessons are clear
as well as the need to show solidarity
with ukraine and its citizens
we have three
clear priorities first
strengthen
seriously
foreign policy and defence policy
we are working on that secondly
diversifying our sources of energy uh
resources drastic reduction of our
dependence on russia
thirdly we have to strengthen our
relations with the united states with a
administration like biden's that is much
closer and sympathetic to european
industry in interest
and we also need to strengthen our links
to nato and
partner countries in this multipolar
world
uh and
a rapprochement
between uh
russia and china could lead us to a
bipolar world that pits the free world
against russia and china
for one minute
thank you madam president
madam prime minister uh the high
representative the events in ukraine
have struck us all
the violence is a threat to our european
peace and it is still unclear what the
consequences the war will have
on our lives
i lived through the war i know what war
means
one thing is certain the world has
changed and the eu has changed with it
within days even ours european member
states have shown their unity by
condemning the aggression and by taking
concrete measures to safeguard our
security
over the last two weeks we have
witnessed why european strategic
sovereignty is so crucial
the eu is showing that it has the
leverage and the power to make proactive
policies to reduce it its dependency to
increase its cooperation with
like-minded partners
although the end game is not yet in
sight
let us use this clear momentum to create
a real security union let us improve our
resilience and defense capacity based
our on strong strategic compass
in cooperation with our transatlantic
partners while managing a crisis today
we should ensure our peace and stability
for tomorrow thank you and let's work
for the peace because families
and
those who are fearing for their loved
ones
only wants a peace at this moment thank
you very much miss zofco i give the
floor next to francois xavier bellamy
for a minute
madam president well no need to recall
all of the statements that we've just
heard
but this
war affects us
broadly and outside these wars it's not
just the freedom and the sovereignty of
the ukrainian people that's threatened
here
they deserve our solidarity but we also
need to preserve the principles behind
peace in the world never should a great
nation
resolve any of its uh disagreements by
violence
never should armies
attack civilians or bombard targets that
have no military relevance that are
rather
humanitarian corridors for families
escaping the war this is not naive
idealism it is simply recalling
international law even war has its rules
even a thousand years ago it was clear
that uh
might was not always right
all of the russian forces involved in
this conflict
are trying to suggest that uh
might shall prevail but we all have a
conscience we all have our own
responsibility
one day justice will be done
and now we have to
question what it means to be a human
being
now in europe
we have to
ensure that we defend our principles and
be in a position to defend those
thank you president uh prime minister
uh colleagues
it was a recent churchill that said that
democracy means that if the doorbell
rings at early hours it is likely to be
the milkman
well ladies and gentlemen it is not the
milkman this day is calling at our
doorbells but bombs missiles misery and
pain
authoritarian regimes that want to
destroy our liberties our freedoms our
way of life are calling to that order
make no mistake
we are the main course in putin's menu
only through the brave and courageous
resistance of our ukrainian brothers and
sisters only through our help to those
who fight for democracy
and the european ideals in georgia in
moldova in belarus the balkans and even
in russia
we will prevail
thanks to them we might give an
opportunity to our children to live the
democratic dream
let's fight outside and inside this
european union the enemies of our
liberties let's start by cleaning our
house of populists and extremists
financed by moscow caracas orteran
europe this is a wake-up call let's show
the world our desire to have the milkman
at our doorstep thank you very much
thank you very much mr lopez is tourists
and that brings us back to prime
minister khalas you see that
you are you enjoy
full support of this
house
in the work that we can do together over
to you
thank you and uh thank you all for this
very very good debate uh i think we are
very much agreeing on on different
topics but i will just point out a few
few things that
that i wanted to react to
first of all
we have been very united during this and
as a eu
also with our transit
atlantic partners and we should keep it
this way um it's going to be tougher
because
you know putin wants to see us divided
and let's not give them uh this pleasure
let's say united i think it's very
important
second
there were some calls for you know
making agreements regarding the security
architecture
the problem is that
the goal of uh putin or russia is to get
those agreements because he knows that
the one of the values of the european
union is that we respect agreements
bhaktas and servanda which means that we
follow the agreements whereas the
russian side is never gonna follow those
so when we talk about you know uh
disarmament or we talk about uh you know
taking down uh military exercises or or
uh limiting uh defense then it actually
means that we are making ourselves
weaker because the other side is not
going to follow those agreements um and
we should not uh do that and also um
there was also somebody who said here
that you know
expanding
nato taking new
members to nato would be provoked
provoking russia well it's not provoking
russia
every country has the right to decide in
which unionists or
allies um
it wants to be
it's not up to any other country to say
that you can't be there and i i remind
you nato is a defense alliance it's not
attacking anybody it's meant to be there
for defending the countries that are in
this alliance and what we see right now
it's very much necessary
so
we shouldn't fall into that trap
regarding
the sanctions
i i think we also should think about you
know one side is seizing the assets but
the other side is also confiscating the
assets so that we can use the means
from those assets to build up ukraine
and and therefore if this signal goes
out then it also means for every bullet
that they fire for every building that
they destroy they're going to pay for
this they're going to build this from
their own money it's coming from their
pockets i think it has to be very clear
regarding this
on energy
we have to understand that it's it's
going to hurt uh and of course uh
ukrainians are suffering now and i do
agree with those who have said that we
shouldn't um
finance the war machine of of putin but
we also have to understand that some of
the countries in europe are 100 percent
dependent on russian gas bulgaria for
example if we don't have
alternatives it's going to hurt them a
lot and maybe so much that
you know there is not going to be unity
uh also within europe we have to see
what are the alternatives how can we
help those uh those countries um so it
wouldn't be so hard on our population
um and
some members said that we are
the eu has emerged stronger from the
crisis and i do agree with this we have
built on the lessons that we learned
from the debt crisis that enabled us to
uh be better in the health crisis you
know we had all the funds ready uh to be
reacting to a possible economic uh fall
fall but
now we also have to use the lessons
learned from previous crisis to be
stronger and i do agree we are stronger
uh here
as well and the last point um no one one
more point before the last point uh and
that is um that the uh representative of
um of uh epp from from france said that
uh the ec
um
defense
clause for article 42 7 has never been
used that actually that is not correct
it has been used once and it was for
france because of the bataclan crisis so
just wanted to uh correct that and and
if some countries who are not members of
nato need this article to be
really you know enforced right now to
say to feel more secure like finland and
sweden then we should
we should agree on this i think it's
it's
nothing we are not giving anything
anything away and the last point
it's about ukrainian
perspective
to join europe
i think
what the ukrainians need right now is
hope
they are literally fighting for europe
in ukraine and the least we can do is
give them this hope and say that yes you
are part of europe you are welcome to
our family thank you
thank you very much
prime minister
khan last thank you to all the
colleagues who participated and stayed
in this
debate until this time
this debate is now closed we will resume
at three o'clock
with miss bonafet's report on batteries
and waste batteries see you then
you